o quadro de pessoal de quem falou dar
que sejam muito bem vindos a marcha
anterior como vocês sabem há já algum
tempo que ainda vai precisar de um pc
novo tumulto nos tirar só eu como a
massa global tatu a oferecer um pequeno
eu estou aqui vejo ruim do windows dó
ver se ele vai ser eu a mostrar como eu
mantenho o psi novo porque o fla loja
gobatto e eu já tinha lá as peças todas
por isso é só montar e espero assistir
tv ouvir a montagem tenta fazer alguma
coisa fani mas é e eu só peço um único
favorito ao passar pelas páginas da
colher mais 30 global vai cantar na
descrição passem por lá e deixa o vosso
grande obrigado essa eu deixei mesmo
passou obrigado lá porque especial vai
servir para fazer foi feliz porque agora
já consigo jogar tudo total passando
também pelo meu inter e grêmio que agora
eu não tenho muitas fotos muitas fotos
ainda estou emocionado pessoal obrigado
também a vocês porque sem vocês eu não
tinha especial
obrigado mesmo não vou brincar é esse
pessoal já sabe quanto vai falar em
favoritos para curto vídeo adelson o que
é isto que estamos na global data eo
asfalto bem vindo a falar é que está o
nosso caro assistente chamado fernando
pires vai estar aqui a montar o meu
pensei vejam só como vc tá gostoso limpa
an é e papel
só vamos trazer um boxe e maravilhoso
como vocês viram e agora vamos passar a
montagem que a parte mais importante né
não há uma só pessoa
agora vou precisar de uma ajuda
essencial não é porque não sei um
parceiro e vamos já exporta feito rio
tejo não vai faltar uma peça de roupa e
uma caixa
só se for uma espécie de caixa de boris
moreno ramos exato coisa que não sei que
é chato fenda chave porque a chave do
portão caixa fils st de outubro x roda
gigante à noite o racha procura pra não
entrar quentinho coisas do evento em
espetacular mas olha aí o que é bonito
fundamentação para o nosso menino
comércio e só
só isso e uma bolsa de cosméticos da
cura master para estarem sempre bonitos
enquanto joga em um e 7 606 mil e 700
capas que é capa
antes que o trem bonita muito ruim com
isso não é vagamente estão black white
vai ser complicado no trecho da nota
para segurar a parte da frente muito
parafuso meu deus
agora foi a parte de colocar coisinhas
nos cabos presos ficarem arrumado
enquanto isso
foco também no inter não é coerente em
enfiar um buraco nos meus dedos num
carro em ajata a tacin rolimã
queremos ter a certeza do parafuso que
acontece um tenista que dentro desses
estudos não renda o seguro tem um
computador embalsamado em 12
paulo
e é isso
acho que já está tudo ruim do brasil
aqui do lado tem um novo amor
uma previsão muito obrigado pela master
do batata inscritos da província